[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
hey welcome back to joke world this is
round two of the march madness podcast
tournament results if you're new here
and you didn't see round one go watch
that right now i know a lot of new
subscribers came in from the tom segura
your mom's house shout out so welcome to
you guys we're doing a tournament based
on our favorite comedians podcast but
march madness style
and then just one other thing based on
that shout out real quick that i want to
mention uh last night actually it was
very exciting christina p followed us on
instagram the main mommy herself so if
christine is following us on instagram
you should definitely be too so the link
is also to our instagram in the bio but
let's get back into the podcast march
madness tournament um we had the elite
eight this round so there were four
match-ups region one the joe rogan
experience against uncle joey's joint a
lot of people were saying the church of
what's happening now would have been
better um in this tournament than uncle
joey's joint was but it's the 2022
tournament and the church what's
happening now has no episodes in 2022 so
you had to go with the joint there then
in region two you had your mom's house
against tiger belly then we had this
past weekend against the king and sting
and then finally two bears one cave
versus the tim dillon show our big match
up of round two so let's start off in
region one with the joe rogan experience
going up against uncle joey joey coco
diaz and uh you know obviously very good
friends this should be a good matchup we
had 4 200 people vote on this
and the joe rogan experience took the
cake
80 to 20 this seems like he's just gonna
dominate the whole tournament i wanted
this to be fair and not be a popularity
contest but he has been rolling over
everyone even the great and powerful
joey diaz really didn't seem to put up
much of a fight tremendous matchup joe's
like beer everyone can get into it
joey's an acquired taste but a little
goes a long way
yeah he's more of like a whiskey
like you know a shot it's
it's gonna startle you at first but you
only need two or three uh to get where
you need to go this does not mean i
don't love uncle joey i gotta go with
rogan his podcast has a couple guests
that have changed my life
that's what i'm saying people have
different connections to the joe rogan
experience than to a typical podcast
speaking of actually we just did part
three of the try not to laugh joe rogan
experience it was posted yesterday uh so
make sure you go check that out if
you're looking for a good laugh on this
sunday but okay so joe rogan moving on
to the final four beats his friend joey
diaz in the second round moving on to
the next match up your mom's house
against tiger belly these are i think
are two of the biggest audiences on
youtube as far as comedians and podcasts
and reach go i'm expecting this to be a
little closer 2 800 people voted on it
and your mom's house just slaughtered
them wasn't even close 74 to 26 ymh
just on a mission this march it it
really seems like they're going to be
the favorites to to probably win this
whole thing some of my favorite episodes
are when these two collab completely
agree that's the thing about this
tournament is that it's not really
saying that one's better than the other
i've i'm a fan of every single podcast
that's been in this tournament obviously
but it's just fun
to spark some competition and to vote
and and move people through through a
tournament tough one only way to choose
is george and nadav in a ginger bow
staff cage match make it happen i'd pay
to see that
i love tiger belly but it doesn't even
compare to your mom's house the
following they have is insane following
wise i'd say these are a little bit
comparable but
sam disagrees not expect this to be so
one-sided that's what i'm saying i did
not see 24 to
uh or 74 to 26 coming but nonetheless
tiger belly um good tournament so far
you had that first round win and that
will always remember against um who did
they play in the first round
we'll always remember it i swear
tiger belly beat whiskey ginger that
yeah you will all you'll always have
that win in the first round against
whiskey ginger that no one will ever
forget and will always remember
especially me hot sauce is the best the
enjoyment i get out of
hot sauce and just
lighting me up like and he knows what
i'm talking about
right
i can't hear you in the headsets i have
headsets on oh yeah i was saying yeah
hot sauce is the best and then and then
and then six hours from then i'm saying
yeah this is the best
like i can't i can't think of a
breakfast burrito without
[ __ ]
fire hustle like just like hey what's
going on everybody for first week feast
i'm shawn evans and you're watching hot
ones
and you're right annie hot sauce is the
best
[Laughter]
[Applause]
moving on to region three which was the
theaven show
literally it was this past weekend
against the king the sting and the wing
two thousand and one hundred people
voted on this and it was 69 nice to 31
percent this past weekend so apparently
when push comes to shove
people will take theo on side over uh
brendan and delia's for the king and the
sting theo by himself is some sort of
very peaceful craziness that no one else
can achieve gang gang brother i'm
upstairs
100 agreed it is
peaceful craziness i've never thought of
those words to describe it but that is
that is very astute
as you all know the comedy podcast march
madness is brought to you by ewin gaming
chairs um i just got my e-win a few
months ago before that i had a chair i
ordered from amazon and the back of that
thing broke within i don't know maybe
two months and i had to kind of use it
like a stool or else the plastic parts
would like stab me in the back and and i
couldn't lean back sometimes i'd forget
and i'd lean back i get stabbed in the
back literally by my old chair but ewin
would never do that to me it's built for
comfort it's built for luxury but most
importantly it's better than any of your
friends or family's chairs so forever
when anyone brings up chairs you can say
oh i have an e-win gaming chair you
don't know what you're talking about
you don't know [ __ ] about chairs i have
an ewin gaming chair so that's really my
favorite thing about it um but you know
there's a ton of great qualities like i
said comfort speed luxury you can get
yourself one of these bad boys for 20
off using the joke world link in the bio
e win gaming chairs there's nothing else
i sit on a lot of comments in this one
debating like
theo by himself or if he needs to get
rid of brendan or just a lot of that
kind of talk that you could expect in
these comments so theo vaughn and this
past weekend again another one seed
moving on to the final four so far the
final four is three out of four one
seeds uh but we have one more matchup to
go today and it's the biggest matchup of
the day it's two bears one cave against
the tim dillon show legitimately two of
my top five favorite podcast 91 comments
on this one 3 600 people voted on it and
the results the percentages were 61 to
39
to two bears one cave so the tim dillon
show
with the elite eight exit of the podcast
tournament honestly the seating was
tough here i mean it went the high
subscriber mount the lowest so i
couldn't really control where the seeds
were but the tim dylan's show having to
start off against bad friends beating
them 52 percent to 48 and then in the
second round having to see two bears i
mean they have gone through by far the
hardest path to the finals um in this
tournament or they had they were
presented with the hardest path i guess
they didn't technically make it but hell
of a fight by the tim dillon show tim
dillon's fans have his back more than
anyone on the internet and they all kind
of act like him too they're all a little
bit angry they're a little bit gay and
they're all a little bit ranty and look
at this tim dillon shows a religious
experience every time you listen anybody
voting against him just doesn't know who
he is tim can't be denied tim is
literally a god on his own and every
podcast he guests on i'm kind of
surprised two bears as being tim dillon
literally wasn't expecting that tim has
the second biggest patreon in the world
and he's the only comedian in my opinion
who goes on other shows as guests and
turns them into another episode of the
tim dillon show votes go for two bears
one cave but all the comments are saying
tim dillon we know the tim dillon show
is better and so do you joke world
tim dillon should have won this one
you should have it's the more impressive
podcast yes or yes
but
it's madness man anything can happen two
bears one cave with the
not upset because they were the higher
seed but 91 other people are upset about
it so
that's our final four it's all the
number one seeds how exciting joe rogan
is going to face off against this past
weekend and your mom's house against two
bears one cave which is obviously the
same production company and it's tom
against tom the final four ended up to
be
maybe exactly what we thought it was
there weren't as many upsets in this
tournament as i thought there might be
here's the other thing dude is
i'm kind of just doing this off of you
know on the fly just how this video is
i
didn't really expect that i thought
voting would be the most fair way to do
this and it turns out that all the one
seeds all the biggest podcasts turned
out in the final four so maybe that
isn't the best way to do this but then
it it's like well then what is you know
because voting seems fair we're getting
4 000 different people to weigh in on
these podcasts one against the other
um
but then you have this comment section
full
of people saying that this is the wrong
choice but then it's 61 to 49 so it's
really it wasn't even that close
so very interesting and
too late to change now so
next saturday will be the voting on the
final four and then the sunday after
will be the video just like this one
discussing the results very exciting
stuff though i'm still happy we're doing
it and the real march madness has been
super exciting also i don't know if you
guys are following that um but i'm a big
sports guy and that's been exciting too
but not even close as exciting as the
joe rogan experience going up against
theo van and this past weekend in the
final four next saturday march uh
saturday march 26th will be the voting
in the community section then the 27th
of march that sunday again will be a
video following um make sure you go
follow joke world on instagram we're
featuring a new comedian every single
day christina p follows us tuesdays with
stories account follows us i mean what
are you doing if you're not following us
on instagram that's a little bit
embarrassing that's it thanks for
watching thanks for voting thanks for
participating in the tournament make
sure you subscribe to joke world on all
social medias and keep having a very
happy and very mad march
was kind of a weird ending i wish i said
like
something better than keep having a bad
did i say bad march
[Music]
you